thank you professor
i'm honest with you again um i have a
question so
you just now you mentioned that you were
more focused on the downside as an
investor
but i think um you admitted also in the
recent podcast you did with professor
um santos that you have a tendency to
go into situations where the outcome
could be binary
because of high leverage and maybe the
turnaround situation
so can you just maybe share with us why
so and how
are you navigating away from them and
for example the experience with horse
head for instance and
with those experience how do you think
about averaging averaging down
right now well so i never deliberately
deliberately go into situations that are
binary
outcomes i mean those those are not
appealing to me
sometimes i end up in situations where
eventually it becomes a binary outcome
or it's gone south so that's that's a
different situation but
i do try hard at the outset
before the investment is made to try to
figure out
what could go wrong and if those things
go wrong what could happen
to our investment results with the
position
and generally speaking we try to not go
into situations
where so investing is probabilities you
know i think
any business has some probability of a
zero
you know it could be very small but it's
not it's not non-existent
so every business has uncertainty in the
future
and could have serious difficulties in
the future
which may not be predictable so we we
can't just say that something is an
absolute
investing in the game of probabilities
what we do want to do is we want to try
to
maximize the probabilities of a good
home run
and minimize the probabilities that we
have a permanent loss of capital
so if things don't work and i
end up with approximately what i started
with
that's a great outcome i would take that
bet all day long
and if things do work then i get a
multi-bagger so if
if that's the kind of equation i'm
looking at
then that equation is very attractive if
the
equation is that there's a significant
probability of a zero coupled with a
very high
also probability of a multibagger that's
not of that much interest
so we definitely want to have downside
protection sometimes we end up in
situations
i mean horsehead is an example
at the time the investment was made it
wasn't a risky investment
what ended up happening is that they
were
trying to build a new plant which
continuously
kept getting delayed and had cost
overruns in the meantime they had shut
down their old plant
and in the end they ran out of runway
you know where their
the zinc prices collapsed and their you
know all their financials went
upside down so it's definitely within a
bell curve
of probabilities but i did not expect it
to be to go to that
extreme end of a bell curve but we
learned you know so one of the things i
learned from that experience
is that you just cannot
assume that when managements embark on
these
you know uh ambitious new plants and
things like that that they will
go as planned you have to put in a
margin of safety
i have another investment right now for
example a company in india called rain
industries which is again
been building some new plants and such
and they've had
some cost overruns and some delays
but it has not impacted the business
because the size of those investments
relative to the
mothership is well understood and
even if those plants never i mean if it
was zero
in those plants for example the business
would not get affected business would
still
survive and thrive and so that was
missing in the horoscope situation
the what if this doesn't work at all so
we live and learn and so that was a good
learning that came out of that
thank you
[Music]
[Music]
you